bueno
creo que siempre va a ser importante
regresar en donde uno dejo parte de su
corazón
y sin duda alguna yo tengo una gratitud
de inmensa con la gente de quevedo con
el pueblo de quevedo y con la
construcción de la ciudad como tal tuve
la oportunidad de en algún momento de
trabajar
en el proceso electoral asesorando a
algunos candidatos en la provincia
algunos ganamos otros perdimos creo que
de eso mismo se trata la vida como tal y
más allá de traerles una presentación o
traerles unas diapositivas que siempre
van a ser importantes lo que yo en esta
charla
he decidido hacerlo decidió compartir
con ustedes es prácticamente mi
experiencia desde el liderazgo y en qué
momento en mi vida hice el switch
para estar donde estoy hoy por hoy en
día para haber ganado los premios que
ganaban que al final de cuentas son
solamente un reconocimiento que de hecho
el premio que mencionó este rey fernando
está en la gaveta del escritorio no es
que lo tengo guindaba en las tragedias
el libro yo todos los días lo veo y me
persigno no está ahí porque al final de
cuentas el objetivo principal era
traccionar en la sociedad
era crear algo y devolverle algo a la
sociedad que yo creía que tenía que
hacer lo que debía de hacerlo
y yo vengo de la empresa privada
me dediqué a un negocio desde
a los 18 o 19 años por ahí tuve mi
primer emprendimiento
me considero y me catalogó como un
emprendedor por naturaleza
y en algún momento decidí salir de la
empresa privada para vincularme la
pública que no es nada sencillo que no
es nada fácil
porque probablemente a diferencia de la
entidad privada en la pública la
competencia desleal es mucho más fuerte
los chismes cuentos de pasillos la falta
de capacidad de las autoridades que
están ahí los directores si hay algún
director de algo municipal que me va a
disculpar pero
no tengo compromiso con nadie no tengo
filtros con nadie tampoco así que
decirles cae pues aguanta esta casa este
pero están construidas justamente para
gente que es muy poco capaz
en ciertos rangos y a veces las
autoridades locales no entienden que con
una buena política pública que con una
buena acción se puede cambiar la vida de
toda la sociedad la vida de todo el
pueblo se puede desarrollar
absolutamente otra ciudad otro juego
y aún así hay decisiones que pasan más
allá por la voluntad política creo que
también tiene que tener un componente de
capacidad
en este sentido les hacía simplemente
ese pequeño resumen
en las elecciones del 2007
si en las elecciones de 2007 yo tenía mi
empresa gerenciaba bonito a las ocho de
la mañana abría me sienta de meritorio
como gerente no sólo con los pies de
arriba pero éste está en una zona
bastante pluma porque era algo que me
apasionaba
los carros
cuando de repente empieza a salir toda
la recta fila de candidatos electorales
y oh sorpresa la gran mayoría era gente
de frank la que con la cual no tengo
nada en contra de la farándula que me
esculpe
esto tiene que cambiar
yo no puedo permitir que sigan pasando
este tipo de actores políticos tomando
decisiones sobre mí o por mí
algo tengo que hacer
y empiezo a pensar que yo pensaba las
vueltas no dormí como una semana
qué es lo que creo que al país le hace
falta
necesito alguna relevo generacional pero
este relevo generacional que venga con
conocimiento de causa
y que tenga realmente la voluntad de
transformar el país porque soy uno de
los convencidos de que ecuador tiene la
capacidad de ser potencia mundial
en lo que quiera en gastronomía en
exportaciones de camarón en flores y
tenemos ciertos ejemplos de lo cual es
el desarrollo del país y de la república
ha sido demostrada pero sin embargo a
veces nos acostumbramos o vemos casos
como las de paola martínez y carlos la
chica de casa caja que nos sorprende
decimos guau pero qué hubiese pasado si
el caso de paola si hubiese hecho diez
años espero que como de nicole perdón de
nicole si se hubiese hecho diez años
atrás
y hace 10 años atrás en esta tierra que
produce mucho cacao que produce mucho
banano se le empezaba a dar valor
agregado a las cosas
sin ser agorero sin ser pitoniso
seguramente quevedo sería la ciudad que
atraiga al mundo entero
y casos como este nos sorprenden hoy por
hoy pero sí y si es nicole pero si no
solamente es una nicole si son 20 niños
si todos los productores de cacao
enfocarán hacia el mismo mercado que
pasaría nosotros dejaríamos simplemente
de exportar materia prima y comprar la
materia prima ya con valor agregado para
los precios que pagamos absolutamente
pero bueno regreso a la idea inicial
ahí decidió crear la primera escuela de
formación política
en ecuador y en latinoamérica por eso
decía
era básicamente para empezar a darle
poder al ciudadano sobre ciertas cosas y
sobre ciertas herramientas y hoy en el
primer 'break' en lo compensaba con
parte de los chicos y decía esta persona
se me acercara en que estoy empezando
acuñado el término bastante colonial que
enseñan a la ciudad como un pie con
cuánta capacidad desde luego
porque mucha gente
no entiende absolutamente nada cómo se
empieza esa ciudad y como bueno la
llevar y transformar nuestras realidades
nuestros entornos
escuela de formación política gana
premios y sin duda alguna también antes
de preparar la presentación hasta el día
ayer estaba en línea powerpoint bonito
con animaciones estado original
yo a la gente que veo tengo una enorme
gratitud y en vista de eso les voy a
contar parte de mi experiencia para
diversidad con alguna ustedes conecto
algunos ustedes logró sacudir obligar a
sus fibras y me pueden decir mañana
adelante perfecto saque
si jorge pudo porque no pueden hacerlo
alguna ustedes
porque para algunos ustedes me van a
ayudar en este momento pero que es
liderar para ustedes
no levanten dos la mano por favor
qué es para usted es liderar porque es
parte del liderazgo
nadie se anima
me quería lisa vamos a hacer dedocracia
dirigir crear perfecto alguien más
es el ejemplo perfecto alcalde
proyectada bien probablemente son partes
de las características que tiene que
tener un líder o una persona que lidera
un equipo
pero eso también viene un conocimiento
ancestral en el cual nos han dicho que
solamente un tipo de persona o una
característica a una persona es la capaz
de liderar las cosas
y nosotros hemos hecho la pregunta a
nosotros mismos en qué tan capaces somos
nosotros en liderar lo que querramos
porque créanme que los estoy bien
ustedes íberos count es un poder brutal
de transformar lo que quieren
sus ciudades sus entornos sus familias
sus casas y por qué no juntos construir
un mejor país es
el estar parado hoy aquí me permite
saber que es posible hacer las cosas
que se puede hacer las cosas escucharlo
eduardo y obviamente me da muchísimo
gusto primero que seamos todos
ecuatorianos arrancando por ahí sin
menospreciar el talento que viene de
afuera
pero que sin embargo gente como cristian
como el doctor y elena como eduardo
y como alguno de los compañeros que
también me han antecedido en la palabra
hemos podido hacer las cosas y son una
muestra clara e incluso hasta como esta
misma actividad de que es posible hacer
en el poste o en las redes sociales
cuando subir la información hoy porque
te veo porque alguien se le ocurrió
montarlo en quevedo y nos ven
simple
si tú quieres hazlo escribirle a la
gente que tiene la licencia y llevar a
guayaquil
y se acabó el problema algo tan simple
que tenemos que trabajarlo aquí arriba
y obviamente el liderazgo no solamente
probablemente nos han enseñado que ese
líder es el que tiene que encajar el que
te tiene que gritar y que te tiene que
estar empujando de atrás pero cada uno
ustedes tiene realmente una habilidad
para poder liderar
en el caso contrario van a morir como el
título de la ponencia pero no tienen sus
sueños oa cuántos de nosotros nos ha
pasado que nos dejamos pasar o nos
dejamos llevar por las circunstancias de
la vida decimos ya mañana habló con el
alcalde la mañana presentó este proyecto
ya mañana van los besos
se han reído algunos porque
probablemente sencilla una empiezo desde
siempre hay un lindo lunes que viene
y parece que al final de cuentas
nuestras
que nos desconecta es absolutamente el
objetivo y hoy aquí han hablado de
ponerle amor a las cosas lo cual estoy
completamente de acuerdo en que el amor
sin duda es el elemento más esencial
pero no solamente lo conversamos con el
bardo no solamente el amor de yo te
quiere no amor está por tu propia tierra
amor por tu país qué fue lo que llevó a
lanzarme a crear este proyecto
como se iba a ver
nunca lo visualizamos que dije esta va a
ser
simplemente eres con esta acción yo lo
que quiero es que mañana salga una nueva
clase política salga del nuevo estilo la
nueva sangre
con gente que conozca gente y empecemos
desde ahí a darle batalla a la
corrupción a una incapacidad
y de empezar a visualizar nuestras
ciudades a corto mediano y largo plazo
que no los hacemos de 5x está trabajando
en un modelo de visión a largo plazo
no sé si que veo lo tengas ya lo dejo de
tarea al alcalde pero probablemente con
el único alcalde con el cual me daba el
gusto de poder conversar sobre esta
visión que la tiene clara el 2050 es con
el alcalde de portoviejo
como el que estamos empezando a trabajar
creo yo una segunda versión
de esta escuela de formación política
que les comentaba al inicio
y con él estamos trabajando la creación
de una escuela de formación ciudadana
en donde se le enseña al ciudadano
con cuántas papas se hace este logro
cuáles son los deberes competencias y
responsabilidades que tiene la autoridad
y él como ciudadano porque si mañana la
autoridad municipal no me responde como
ciudadano yo tengo todo el deber de
poder si el señor alcalde usted es un
incompetente no me sirve varias en su
casa
busco los formularios presento
revocatoria de mandato y se fue porque
de nuevo
y en mejorar la cosa que quiera mejorar
en sus vídeos
así como lo que me toca
a mí para a través de esta escuela de
formación ciudadana
espero el proyecto lo terminemos
cerrando antes de que cierre el año que
con presupuesto municipal puede trabajar
y puede darle tranquilamente
capacitación a la ciudad y le empieza a
empoderar
en el plan de desarrollo y ordenamiento
territorial le enseña a la gente cuáles
son los deberes y competencias
y espero que esta escuela no solamente
se haga por tu bien sino que recorre
absolutamente todo el país
porque les insisto que deber ser es
aportar desde esa cancha desde esa parte
al desarrollo del ecuador
y poder medirme dormir tranquilo a mi
casa diciendo todos los días hoy he
hecho lo que tenía que hacer para ver
mejor mi país hoy he hecho lo que tenía
que hacer para poder ayudar a mi entorno
y sin duda alguna por el lado del amor
viene con este compromiso que adquirí no
solamente con mi país
si no conmigo me
y probablemente por la persona
no la persona que más amo en este mundo
pero si alguien que me enseñó y me dio
una razón más para poder luchar que mía
y por la cual en el momento que tendré
yo juré firmemente ante ella devolverle
un ecuador
devolver lo mejor países
y no de carga y no descansaré hasta no
ver es
hasta no vivir
voy a cuidar lo fácil es positivo pero
atrás de esto también han habido
traiciones
han habido un montón de cosas que sin
duda alguna sesión debiese llevar por
las circunstancias probables
y le comentaba eduardo en el break que
estuviera arriba o tirado dejándome
llevar por la corriente por la marea
pero sin embargo el camino no es fácil
como nada es fácil en la vida
y como sin duda alguna la invitación
para ustedes es salir puede ser
desecharlo a salir de este evento pero
cuestionándose a que se comprometan
ustedes para hacer mejor su entorno a
qué se comprometen ustedes para trabajar
mancomunadamente con su autoridad número
uno que es el alcalde que es el
ciudadano uno que tiene esta ciudad y
poder trabajar es un proyecto que
realmente le devuelva el autoestima al
ciudadano quevedeño y trabaje en una
visión de largo plazo sin intereses
sinceramente con el ánimo de la sociedad
en él se siente que realmente debería
entonces una invitación a hombres
después de comentarle un poco todas las
experiencias
s
a qué te complemente el día de hoy
a qué te complemente en este momento es
en silencio
por tu país para hacer para hacer puerto
familia núcleo humano
te lo dejo de respuesta de preguntas
portela responda y al final después de
esto
re no me pongo porque eso es todo más
como una para trabajar por un mejor y 4
muchísimas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]